once users have accessed your homepage
or your application you will likely want
the user to register for an account but
this isn't always the case you should
keep in mind that registration doesn't
have to be the next immediate step in
your process you should just think
carefully about the entire user
experience the product you're offering
and when you want registration to happen
if you want registration to happen at
all
registration on Udacity site is fairly
simple with just a couple fields or you
could also login using Facebook or
Google for more detailed examples of
signups and onboarding check out user
onboard comm which is linked in the
instructor notes you can walk through
examples such as Gmail to see all the
design elements that guide first-time
users these details include animations
text annotations tooltips and calls to
action all of these lead the user to
successfully using the product for the
first time now there are many ways to
build out a successful onboarding
experience and our best piece of advice
is to test your ideas with users using
wireframes and mock ups we'll cover how
you can do this with a design sprint in
the next lesson to get a real sense of
why testing is important check out this
article about Yammer sign up flow the
company found very counterintuitive
results by adding just one step to the
registration flow